Okay Michael, so
I think we're done with this section.
So it's time for
you to tell me what have we learned?
>> So, this was the section on
generalizing generalization and scaling.
>> Right.
>> So, we connected that idea
with function approximation,
which was the section that I did.
>> Right.
So, we talked about generalization
beyond function approximation.
>> To function approximation.
>> And beyond!
>> [LAUGH] To function approximazation.
And beyond!
>> Okay.
And what kind of
generalizations did we do?
>> So, we did temporal abstraction.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And in particular, we talked
about temporally extended actions.
>> Mm-hm, or?
>> SMDPs?
>> Well, options.
>> Right, right, right.
>> And SMDPs.
And, what does SMDP stand for?
>> Semi markup decision processes.
>> That's right, just like the truck.
>> Right,
a semi markup decision process.
>> Exactly.
>> And so, SMDP with 18 wheels.
>> Yes.
So, we learned about options in temporal
abstraction, which is really cool.
And what else?
>> I want to say that led
us to goal abstraction.
>> It did, as a matter of fact.
And in particular, do you remember?
>> Mediating between the different
goals, competing goals.
>> We did, and that had a larger name.
We talked about modular
reinforcement learning.
>> Right.
I should remember that because I
was alive when phones were modular.
That was like a big deal.
>> Nobody was alive when
phones were modular, Michael.
In any case,
one of the things that we got out-
>> I was alive before phones were
modular and I was alive when
they switched to being modular.
>> [LAUGH] You're such a hipster.
Okay, so we talked about modular RL or
MRL as the kids call it, and
the word you were searching for
before, I think, was arbitration.
>> Arbitration!
It just seems so arbitrary.
>> That's right.
We talked about one other kind of
abstraction, you might recall.
>> State abstraction?
>> Yeah, state abstraction.
>> We got to state abstraction
from the temporal abstraction.
>> That's right.
But not only do we get some state
abstraction from the temporal
abstraction, that is, not having
to pay attention to all possible,
all states for all particular options,
it actually turns out that state
abstraction is sort of what
function approximation is doing.
>> Hm, okay.
All right, Yeah.
>> All right?
>> Yeah.
So, I think that's pretty cool.
Was anything else that we learned?
I don't think so.
Well, we had a name for
at least temporal abstraction,
we should at least mention that,
nothing else,
that this is a form of hierarchical.
>> And we talked about
quintessential search, but
I think we actually meant quiescence.
>> We did, [LAUGH], and
what does quiescence mean?
>> Quietness.
>> Right, and in particular
it means that you are forced-
>> In the search it means that there's
not all this crazy search
backtracking stuff happening anymore.
Things have settled down and
you know exactly what the next
thing is going to be.
>> Right.
>> So everything is settled.
>> Right, and once things are settled,
then you might as well not
count it against your search.
It has no more sort of
exponential hit on your search.
>> Right.
>> You're forced.
We can treat it as almost as
if it's a single move, say, or
a single action because once you do
this the next thing's happening,
the next thing's happening, the next
thing's happening and [INAUDIBLE]